Kevin your dad you started too young
your dad was really kind of important in
your career my dad I used to drive me in
the gigs because I was I was too young
it performed in the clubs so that would
make for long as I brought along a
parent which is play on kill having to
bring uh no ants in at your RA to go
onstage in these comedy clubs and it
used to drive me everywhere all over
Scotland but you've been very nice
you've rewarded them handsome
you gave your parents a lovely trip was
it the orange express you sent them on I
my dad's always to hang for trains he
always wanted to go on the Orient
Express so for their anniversary a
couple years ago I got them the trap and
my dad is the only guy who's ever messed
the train off the ends block station is
send me a text and he's just still it
taught me me on the formula I've been on
trains and gone dad the monetary in the
second was pretty bad so he presumes you
cannot send the text from a train why -
I'm driving through a cross country so
he gets off before the trains depart and
he starts sending me nice big long texts
just going son we've been waned and
dined I'm gazing at the Tyrolean
mountains and he's done the spell check
beat last X I'm can i fella not just go
nice really had a good time and it just
goes shake and it's meant the train has
just left
it's a wind-up Slovak Norbert and then
an art extra man go and call me son
fund them it does the national ranked 1
in school I just got off the scent that
takes your mom's on else she's get a
passport station and I was gone well you
need to go to your information and try
and explain to something and it goes up
there they don't know what I'm saying
any gentlemen know it or anguish today I
think it's just an exciting Scottish
Gaelic seem the Audion experience and
then eventually he's explained what's
happened and the go and a taxi and he
the contact is on the on the train it
pull another scan original stop and my
dad was a high-speed sort of chase it
managed to catch the train and they go
on and they get outstanding
Lily can you understand anything I know
I got something about balls Charley like
blend in and you know research and just
getting heckled left and right about you
know come spend some time in my shell
baby